in few minutes uh thank you for joining
us uh it's fantastic to have you all on
board uh I'm Rasha Khan I'm your host
for today's webinar and I'm joining from
all the way from Bangalore India and uh
you can drop us a hello and let us know
where are you tuning in from and uh this
webinar is global so basically let the
global conversations begin um you can
let us know on chat box here your name
and where are you joining us from before
we start it's a good way to network
right these events so before we start
and uh in today's webinar we'll be
talking about how you can uh Ace your
next IML interview with the experts we
already have our expert speaker here
with us amindra shast amindra where are
you joining us from hey rash I'm joining
from Hyderabad India
awesome I can see folks have joined from
Bangalore I can see prakash has joined
from Mumbai I can see sandep has joined
from madha Pradesh bopal
Rahul has joined from New Delhi I can
see JY from
Hyderabad I can see prianka has joined
from Kolkata here mul from Bangalore
Raju from up utar Pradesh Arjuna from
Himachal pradish
Hur I can see Mohammad has from Saudi so
keep the introductions coming in I can
see a lot of introductions coming in on
chat here that's great they've gotten a
really amazing audience here with active
partic on the chat here that's great
keep up the energy while we do the
session as well uh because we would love
to know any thoughts any you know
insights you even have if you would love
to share and obviously if you have any
questions about uh you know any
interview questions which you might face
which you have faced how to answer that
better so we'll be uh moving forward I
can see a lot of folks are still joining
in and settling in so meanwhile uh keep
the introductions coming in on chat here
and uh we will quickly go through the
ground door is here before we start uh
so uh you can put on your questions in
the Q&A box in case you have a question
for our speaker here uh what happens is
we get a lot of messages on chart here
and we might miss it and we would love
to address all of your queries uh and uh
keep it keep the questions related to
the session topic here AIML interviews
or AIML career in general any questions
you have about that we'll try to take as
many questions as possible throughout
the session and towards the end as well
the session is being recorded so in case
you want to go through the recording of
the session again you can expect follow
of email with recording link and the
bonus offer and for the session you'll
be getting a webinar certificate as well
uh for that you need to request a proof
of attendance for this webinar uh you
can provide your full name in the post
webinar survey uh based on you know what
a name basically would want uh to be
there on the certificate of the webinar
so I can see the introductions are still
coming in that's great uh let's start so
U the pro this program is powered by
simply learn world's number one online
boot camp
uh we are very proud We have been in the
digital skills training space for almost
13 years now and we have advanced over 5
lakh plus careers in over 150 plus
countries and uh we have 800 plus
qualified trainers uh we have uh
multiple categories like AI machine
learning data science business analytics
cyber security devops cloud computing
and many more uh which this slide can
cannot cover so again like once again
welcome uh to the webinar here so uh
this free interview prep master class on
IML we'll be covering these agendas uh
we'll be starting to getting to know a
little bit more about you how we can
help you better in your AML career and
uh we'll be uh talking about the live
interview prep master class for AIML and
uh if you have any questions basically
anything any question about basically
you might face in an you already faced
you can let us know in the Q&A box as of
speaking uh uh I can see that uh folks
have already started started asking
questions so that's great for I can see
you have basically come prepared to ask
questions uh so keep the questions
coming in and we'll be talking about
program introduction here the
professional certificate program in AIML
uh by IAT cono and we'll be taking you
through the enrollment steps of the
program and as I've mentioned earlier
there'll be special duration for the Q&A
part so in case we are not able to
address your queries throughout the
session so don't worry we'll be answer
answering it towards the end so uh yeah
so as said that we'll be starting the
session by getting to know you a little
better so uh we would love to know how
many years of experience do you
currently have uh for folks who have
joined us you can see a quick pull on
your screen uh here you can select the
most suitable experience uh from the
options we have currently studying zero
to three years of experience three to
five years of experience and the last
one more than five years of experience
as I I speaking I can see the move PS
have already started uh
moving
uh I can see one of our Elm have also
joined us Raju hey Raju hi welcome he's
already an alumni in the IML course by
it Kor so I think Raju if you have any
questions you might be facing in an
interview uh with AIML you can let us
know in the Q&A box we will make sure to
answer that because you have already
enrolled to the program so you already
might be basically uh facing those
interview questions or I'm not sure like
if you have completed the program yet or
not so feel free to let us know welcome
once again so I can see as I was
speaking folks have already shared the
responses how many years of experience
do you currently
have um so I'll just give 10 seconds
more for the poll here before we start
the
session okay I I can see that a lot of
you are messaging us on chat here with
your doubts so just to let you know that
uh there is a Q&A box just beside the
chart box which we which basically we
are conversing here so we usually take
questions from there because we when we
start the session we'll get a lot of
messages on chat here and we would love
for you to engage on the chat so just
just for that just to separate the Q&A
part you can put down your questions in
the Q&A box and we have already got in
questions in the Q&A box so that's
interesting before we have even started
the session awesome I think uh most of
the folks have already voted for this
poll here how many years of experience
do you currently have so let me quickly
end the poll now and also share the
results with your folks and Amit here as
well so as we can see that uh folks 48%
of the folks who have joined us have
more than five years of experience uh
well that's great and uh we can see 31%
of the folks have zero the of experience
and few of the folks who have joined us
are currently studying or have three to
five years of experience so thank you so
much for sharing that with us and as we
start this session I would like to
introduce our guide here and speaker Ami
sastav Ami first of all welcome uh to
the session and thank you for taking the
time out for take King the folks to the
interview prep master class forl would
you like to introduce yourself to the
crowd here hey thanks Rasha always
pleasure to be here hello everyone this
is amendra I'm truly delighted to be
here with all of you today uh my name is
amitra and you can call me Amit uh and
and just to give you a quick
introduction I'm a stats graduate and
then I did my MBA in it and then started
my career with HDFC Bank uh and uh
over over the years I have privilege of
working with different companies overall
I have accumulated over 16 years of of
corporate experience and my journey in
in corporate world has been defined by
my passion for analytics and statistical
Concepts and this passion has driven me
to excel in the field of training
delivery and analytics product
development both and over the years I
have had incredible opportunity to work
with some remarkable organizations and
individuals and I have had the privilege
of training corporate organizations in
data science artificial intelligence and
machine learning accumulating over 4,500
hours of training experience and it's
been a deeply rewarding experience to
empower professionals with the Knowledge
and Skills to harness the power of these
transformative technologies that we talk
about and in addition to my training
Endeavors I'm proud to be associated
with esteem institution like P
University and calch through my
partnership with simply learn and uh
this is where I I teach pgp program
their pgp program I teach machine
learning and and and and advanced deep
learning Concepts and parall uh I also
wear the hat of entrepreneur I
co-founded a company called intica which
I'm running since last 10 years so that
in a nutshell what I have been doing
guys um thank you so much amind for
introduction again once again welcome uh
to the session uh as we will be starting
the interview prep Master Class here how
we can basically Ace your next year and
interview with expert tis here uh before
before we start uh we would love to know
U like why exactly are attending this
interview prep master class for AML
today so you can see a quick pull on
your screen this is a multiple choice
question so you can s multiple options
here because they can be multiple
reasons for joining this interview prep
Master Class here right so as I was
speaking folks have already started
sharing their responses on the poll here
that's great as I said we have gotten
really active uh responsive audience
here so uh I would like love to see that
activeness on the Q&A box here as well
we already have questions in the Q&A box
before we have started that's great but
if you have any particular interview
question you want to ask a doubt about
you can let us know in the Q&A box we'll
be taking those pretty soon so I just
read out those options here basically
why are you attending this interview
prep master class today so this is to
understand how we can basically help out
you better and uh the first one here is
uh enhance my interview skills specific
to a IML positions second one U mastered
effective strategies for answering AIML
related questions third one Tor my
responses to diverse AIML interview
types and and last one navigate
challenging AML scenarios and impress
potential employees so that's that's
equally important uh so I'll just give
10 seconds more for the folks who are
still basically thinking about it and in
case this poll does not cover your
answer you can let us know in the chat
here as well or in the q& Box you know
as you're comfortable so uh most of the
folks have already shared their
responses here I'll just give five
seconds more for the PO before we start
the interview prep Master
Class so 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly end
the poll and also share the results with
you folks uh so as we can see we have
gotten the highest amount of votes
84% for the first option here enhance my
interview skills specific tol positions
and we have gotten 54% votes for master
effective strategies for answering AML
related questions and uh 49% votes for
navigating uh challenging IML scenarios
and impressing potential Empire employes
and we have gotten 36% votes for taor my
responses to divers AIML interview types
so I think thank you so much for sharing
that with us this basically gives us a
better understanding you know in which
direction we need to go and uh we will
basically be starting the interview of
master class now so let's start with the
skills you know the skills uh you need
to have to be an AML practitioner so
before we even go to the uh interview
your questions here so am can you take
us through the skills which are required
to become an AML practitioner in today's
world sure Rasha so uh if you see on
your screen we are starting with the
foundational skills which talks about
statistics and maths this would be your
foundational skills basically to
understand the learning algorithm in a
better manner you should have
understanding of some mathematical
Concepts and as well as statistical
Concepts some of the statistical
concepts are also useful in drawing
certain certain inferences from the data
and making decision on top of that so
that comes very handy so you start with
the basics of statistics and little
Advanced part as well then go through uh
some some basic maths talking about
algebra talking about coordinate
geometry uh your vectors matrices all
that you just cover and then get into
Python and its librar so python think of
it as a as a helping hand and get the
understanding how how python works and
what are the different libraries which
you can use in your data science Journey
so that's what you should start with
that you should have that that skill set
for sure and then you move to machine
learning algorithms so you talk about we
you have to cover supervised
unsupervised learning reinforcement
learning could be semi-supervised
learning and within each framework
you'll have different kinds of algorithm
like emble learning is part of your
supervised learning recommendation
system could be developed using
supervised as well as unsupervised
learning algorithms so you need to learn
those algorithms and there'll be a huge
number of algorithms that you should be
acquainted with and you should know how
do they work because different data set
might be suitable for different kind of
algorithms so you never know what will
work for you then once you are done with
the machine learning part the learning
methods which is mentioned then you move
to the advanced topics uh which is uh
which is basically deep learning in uh
predominantly so you work with the
neural networks over there how do they
work and there are different types of
neural network different architectures
are there so get familiarity with all
that then uh the recent developments
which has taken place especially in
generative advisal networks or any
generative AI algorithm that you talk
about you should get uh understanding of
those algorithms as well and then once
you will have understanding of these
Advanced algorithms you can take those
those those algorithm and apply in in
image processing or or text generation
so that will cover your computer vision
and NLP so that's what the entire path
should be start with the foundational
skills and eventually you should
understand how deep learning algorithms
work uh that sounds pretty interesting
those are those skills uh basically take
up as an EML practitioner thank you so
much for taking us to that
am and uh let's move on to the career
paths you know these skills basically
open up so many career paths in the IML
uh as we can see on the screen you know
we a lot of these career paths but I'm
pretty sure there are so many more
career paths you know beyond these which
folks can take up if you if you talk
about artificial intelligence or machine
learning you think about becoming an
artificial intelligence engineer or a
machine learning engineer but it's more
than that right so can you tell us a
little bit more about that I can talk
about these job profile job roles which
are there let's start with the machine
learning engineer so if I have to tell
you about the responsibilities of a
machine learning engineer it would be
designing an implementing machine
learning applications uh developing and
deploying uh models machine learning
models and different optimization
algorithms that's what the
responsibility would be the the key
responsibilities I'm talking about and
if you talk about experience generally
machine learning Engineers generally two
to five years of experience in software
engineering or data science with a
strong understanding of machine learning
algorithm programming and software
development will be preferred that's how
generally it goes so that's your machine
learning engineer and then you have data
engineer data Engineers would be
responsible for building and maintaining
data pipelines so basically uh before
you apply machine learning models
whatever kind of data processing is
required that that will be taken care by
data engineer engineers so maintaining
data pipelines data warehousing or data
infrastructure that you are building all
that would be part of data engineering
job they will ensure that data Avail
data availability and quality for the
analysis is is up to the mark That's
What data engine will do and uh
generally people coming from database
management or data architecture would be
preferred but if you have good
understanding of SQL or or ETL generally
extract transform load ETL processes and
data warehousing te Technologies then
you can think of data engineering jobs
then uh we have ai architect and AI
architect would be uh designing and
overseeing the implementation of AI
Solutions defining the entire
architecture and infrastructure needed
for AI applications and ensuring uh
scalability and performance which is a
very
important task that they have to carry
out and generally a architect would be 5
to 10 years of experience in AI machine
learning and and software architecture
along with a strong understanding of
various AI Technologies Frameworks and
their
applications then you have ai developer
AI developer will be responsible for
developing AI applications coding and
implementing AI algorithm so they will
be writing the entire code for the AI
algorithms and and also integrating AI
Solutions into existing system systems
so that would be AI developer and then
you have data scientist data scientist
the job would be analyzing complex data
set developing some statistical model or
machine learning models and deriving
actionable insights from the data to
solve business problems their core job
would be to analyze the data and the
data could be complex it could be
unstructured it could be structured
doesn't matter so that's what the main
job of data scientists would be and
typically once you grow in this
particular job role your your job role
will transform into a senior data
scientist and from there you can move to
uh uh uh either into management probably
or you can move into into AI development
ai ai architect and all that's how it
goes so those are the job roles that we
are talking about
here uh thank you so much for taking us
through these career paths inl uh moving
on to the interview prep questions here
forl uh so the first one we have here
these are the most asked basically
interview questions we have have picked
up and uh as we you were speaking we
actually have a lot of questions in the
Q&A box as well you know the interview
questions we'll take those maybe in
between but the first one here is why
did you choose AML as a career path so
I'm before even answering you know how
to answer this I would actually love to
ask you like you know why did you choose
a as your career path I think folks
would love to
know mine was if you asking about mine
it would was more of a natural uh
uh path for me to take up this
particular job because I was doing
statistics and I was very keen in in
terms of working with the data so what I
have realized over the period of time
that if you have this Knack of working
with the data or or you you have this
Knack of analyzing a particular situ
situation scenario back with the data
then this is what you should choose and
and and and automatically this passion
for the problem solving that you're
talking about will develop over the
period of time even if initially you
thinking you're not into it because
because once you start working with the
data that particular part where you have
to define a problem and then and then
acquire some data and start solving it
gives you a lot of lot of satisfaction
when you are working on a real-time
problem so if you ask me I was into
statistics and I was into statistics
because I was probably good at maths at
my childhood so that's how it went but
uh thankfully I I I got into this
because I I over the period of time I
have realized that I really have uh the
first sentence that you have mentioned
passion for problem solving and that's
what has led me to this particular
path wow that's interesting uh now for
someone basically who is just starting
out and uh you know an interview as them
why did you choose AML as your career
path so people folks here are coming
from different different fields they're
transitioning to AIML as a career path
so what would you recommend them you
know uh how would they respond to a
question like this in an
interview okay one of the things
definitely they should mention in some
of the other manner that they are
passionate about solving a problem with
the data which way they want to put it
across their wish they can paraphrase
that but they have to tell this in some
of the other manner that they have
realized over the period of time that
they they are good at problem solving
and U they're more they're they're
logical they're more organized
structured in problem solving and and
that's where they they have chosen this
particular path and uh and at the moment
this is the path which is giving you a
good opportunity in terms of applying
these skill set that they have and
that's a way that's why they have chosen
so I would say that somewhere you have
to mention in some some language that
that you you are good at problem solving
and that's what is key key key part to
start
with because when you talk about any
other other thing like if I say uh
continuous learning that you have
mentioned which is a very key key aspect
of machine learning and AI career
because every day something new is
coming up but you can correlate that
with some other field as well that that
there also is a continuous learning you
can think of but the problem solving
which is happening these days is
entirely revolving around Ai and mln
that's what you have to you have to put
it
across uh that sounds very interesting U
like how would you recommend folks to
basically maybe personalize the answer
as well you know like basically
something they like doing you know like
the way you said you know that
mathematics is something you were always
interested in uh so how would how would
they basically personalize the question
as answer as well you know when they
answer if you want to personalize is
basically you can say something like
this if you really ask me uh uh probably
I can say that my passion for
understanding and leveraging the power
of data to solve complex problem has has
uh taken me to this particular part or
has helped me to to choose this
particular career and over the over the
period of time I have realized that the
that that the transformative potential
of AIML in various Industries um uh has
uh or you can put it across like this
witnessing the transformative potential
of AIML in various Industries I was
drawn to its capacity to to to drive in
Innovation and create meaningful
Solutions
and uh furthermore my fascination with
the intersection of technology and human
intelligence has inspired me to to delve
deeper into realm of AI and ML and I
recognize the opportunity to contribute
uh to the to the development of
intelligent system that can learn adopt
and make some informed decision and
that's how I have come to this
particular job role or or path that
you're talking about
uh thank you so much aindra for
answering that I think that makes pretty
sense but there are no correct ways to
answer right there are so many ways they
can take up right and personalize it I
hope this basically helps you folks now
moving on to the next question here uh
so the next interview question which we
have here is can you describe a specific
AIML project you have worked on
including the problem your approach and
the outcome so projects basically being
uh the most important thing for someone
who basically has not worked in the EML
field right and we even covering this
program we have so many Hands-On
projects which we can work on and
basically acttiv the which we'll talk
about later but yeah like this basically
seems to be the most asked question as
well you know in an
interview sure so I I saw one question
also on this that uh somebody asked that
they have some of the interviews that
they have gone through the question was
asked in terms of what's the approach
overall and and the generic approach
that they have asked so I want to I want
to answer both the questions one that
that is there on your screen and also
what was asked in Q&A so the generic
answer for any machine learning project
that you talk about is if you ask me you
you simply search for crisp DM it's
called c r
ipdm okay so I I'll do one thing I'll
write it down I hope you don't mind
Russia so here uh there's something
called crisp
DM
okay on your screen you can see it so
Cris DM is cross cross industry standard
procedure for data mining and that's a
very good uh framework to apply into
machine learning so it starts with the
business understanding uh the domain
understanding or business understanding
that you then the next step would be a
problem statement or the or or the
business uh uh question that you are
solving that you are answering then it
talks about data acquisition then data
reparation model building uh model
evaluation and deployment so that's a
very generic step I'm giving you over
here okay so it talks about a a standard
procedure for data mining which you can
easily you can take it up in in machine
learning project now to to give you a
little example over here like it says
here can you describe a specific AIML
project you have worked on I can give
you a couple of examples probably that
will help and this is how you can put it
across if you're talking about specific
project then like for example I can say
uh if somebody ask me this question that
uh can you describe a specific AIML
project you have worked on and including
the problem even if they do not mention
that include the problem statement you
start with this like for example i'
would say the problem statement was uh
the company was experiencing a high
churn rate for the customers uh which
led to a loss of Revenue and decline in
customers SA
satisfaction understanding and
predicting customer churn was a
critical was was critical for the
businesses sustainability and growth
that was the problem and then the
approach will come as then I'll start
with the the data acquisition so
probably I can explain what kind of data
I had so I can say we I had customer
demographics which had age gender
location and other relevant demographic
details of the customer we also had
subscription usage metric like usage
pattern including the frequency of
logins durations and subscription and
all we also had engagement metrics like
metrics related to customer engagement
such as the number of interaction with
the customer support feedback provided
billing information was given customer
interactions have been given whenever
they have interacted with us that was a
data I had and then the approach was
first I started with the data
pre-process so I could mention the
techniques that I used for data cleaning
like handling missing values and
outliers or data integration that I had
to do because data was sitting at
different silos or I can talk about
feature engineering that I did feature
engineering and and so all this part I
can put in my Approach first point data
pre-processing technique so I conducted
extensive data cleaning handling missing
values and outliers I also perform
feature enging to extract relevant
customer Behavior metrics from the
subscription log and I can create some
some examples that this is what this was
what was given to me and this is what I
did then next part I would say that then
I have chosen a machine learning
algorithm I tried different algorithms I
tried logistic regression I tried
decision tree I tried tried random
Forest probably I tried I I tried a XG
boost some of these algorithms I tried
and then I tried to predict the
likelihood of customer CH based on the
historical data and I also use
techniques like cross validation to
ensure that models is reliable for for
the use so that that's my next step that
I am talking about and I I'll go in
detail I'm giving you a very short
description over here then next thing
I'll talk about is validation and
optimization of the model lot of people
they miss out on the optimization of the
model they said they validated or they
evaluated the model with the appropriate
uh uh evaluation technique probably they
look for they look for precision and
recall or F1 score for a classification
problem what they don't mention
generally is how do they optimize the
model so you need to talk about like if
I'm using random Forest I can mention
the model was overfitted or I had a very
bad recall value and then I worked on
that or I had
a a data set which was imbalanced so I
needed to work with that or I had to do
some hyper parameter tuning so you need
to explain that in detail which gives
you g gives this idea that you have
indepth knowledge of these algorithms
you do not have a superficial knowledge
you understand that if I have a random
forest model I can use a minimum sample
split to tune the model and per so that
it will perform better so that's what
you need to mention in detail especially
the optimization part nobody talks about
in general I'm saying then eventually
you you talk about the out come that
what was the outcome of this project
once you finish the project generally
what people say I built the model we
deployed and then end of story don't
stop there go to the outcome part and
then you start writing that or start
telling that that what kind of impact it
has created on the company so then you
can say outcome like like in this
example I can say uh achieved meaningful
insights or Solutions like like
developed model successfully predicted
customer churn with a higher degree of
accuracy and which help the company to
proactively identify atrisk customers I
can say improved decision- making
process enhanced overall efficiency and
outcomes I have to give the outcome also
that what what it has what it has
brought to the company when you have
done the analysis so that's how you
should you should generally answer you
should not simply talk about that these
are the steps I took I build the model I
deploy no go in detail little bit more
detail
and then what you should do that there
is is talk about those things which are
really you're more comfortable generally
like if I'm very good at suppose
optimization I'll I'll I'll definitely
talk little extra on that so that they
can ask more question on that if you're
not going to mention something which
you're really confident about they will
not ask more question on that they will
move to the next topic so this is a
small thing I always did when I was
doing uh I was giving uh interviews that
what whichever topic I was very
confident about uh purposely I I used to
spend little extra time on that and then
on that they will start asking more
question and that way it will go the way
I want it to go so that's what you can
do on this particular question I hope
this is making sense to all of
you um please do let us know on chat
here but I must say that is like very
well answered Amel thank you for giving
us a very detailed answer an explanation
also you know how basically you can
answer this question uh about the
projects here so now moving on to the
next one uh like the next question here
is can you discuss a challenging problem
you encountered in your AML work and how
you basically resolved
it okay if you ask uh in my case one of
the problem that that I faced a lot was
initially when I was working with some
government houses was Data integration
task not on the analysis task but the
data inte integration task was was was
quite baffling for us because some of
these organizations were using really
old Legacy systems they had data in
cobal they had data in some of the
system which nobody uses now and we had
to integrate that data to give overall
pictures that was a a big task for us
apart from that uh generally uh one
common challenge that you will come
across is imbalanced data set and I'm
not very sure if you guys are familiar
with that or not but that's a typical
classification problem when you're doing
a classification algorithm you come
across with imbalanced data set so you
should be prepared with the answer like
this you can mention that one challenge
that I faced was imbalanced data set and
and particularly when I do
classification which leads to biased
model that prioritize the majority class
and which will affect the model's
ability to accurately predict the
minority clause and and uh to address
this issue uh I generally try resampling
techniques it could be oversampling or
under sampling technique or within that
I can go for for say synthetic minority
oversampling technique which is called
SM to balance the data set that's one
way I look into it or I might also
choose a better algorithm which might
actually take care of the class
imbalance like some of the Ensemble
modeling technique takes care of the
imbalanced classification issue ose like
I can use XG boost or I can use random
forest for that which can handle skew
data more effectively or and and also
what I do is I if I have imbalanced data
I performance metrics when it comes to I
utilize appropriate metric to understand
how the model is doing so I check for
precision I check for recall I check for
F1 score I also check for Au or
Precision recall curve all that I check
to understand if model is actually
performing well or not and then
sometimes even feature Engineering also
help in taking care of this imbalance
classification issues sometimes the
model itself has a provision for for uh
applying weights to different classes so
these are the techniques I Ed to
overcome this particular problem so this
is one example I'm giving you
guys okay uh thank you so much amra for
answering that uh with so much detail
and I think we've just gotten one
message that all this may sound new to
us because we are yet to go to there uh
with our current AML course so I think
keeping in mind the biger sense also so
this this uh this webinar is actually
for folks who are actually going out
there and giving an interviews I
understand your concern here um so
moving on to the next question here so
the next question we have which is most
asked in the interviews is what is the
difference between supervised and
unsupervised learning on guess I'll I'll
tell one thing here first in machine
learning class you'll be taught this and
everyone will understand what's a
difference so you explain them properly
what's supervised learning unsupervised
learning give examples also a business
example that this this kind of problem
is supervised learning like if a
transaction is fraudulent or not is
supervised learning unsupervised
learning you can say when you want to do
a customer segmentation that's your
unsupervised learning the difference is
is basically on the on the on the label
part supervised learning has a labeled
data unsupervised learning has unlabeled
data if some of you do not are not aware
of this do not worry it will be taught
to you but what I want to tell you is
that when you are telling the difference
always give some business examples and
also the algorithms which are part of
each type of learning so when I say
supervised learning I'll Define it what
it is then I'll say like for example
supervis learning could be stock
prediction or it could be weather
prediction it could be uh if a if a if a
image is of a dog or a cat probably and
algorithms that would be predominantly
used in this would be and then you can
mention different algorithms you can say
under regression I can try linear
regression or I can do I can do a rge
regression or or lasso regression which
is basically helping me to uh uh
regularize the models linear regression
model or under classification I can try
decision Tre or support Vector machines
similarly under unsupervised learning
Give an example that we can do a
customer segmentation based on the
transaction patterns probably and then
uh the algorithms would be a clustering
algorithm could be K means could be
agglomerative or it could be it could be
say you are you are doing a uh market
masket analysis so that's what you need
to mention you need to mention which
algorithm and what
example uh thank you so much amra for
answering that in a very simple uh way
so we have taken a lot of the these
interview questions for AIML here uh we
will be taking a lot of questions while
as we were speaking in the Q&A box here
as well uh we even have like few simply
learn alni who have recently joined the
course I think that will also give folks
a better idea you know what questions
even a alni might have right while they
taking up the course so before we move
on uh we we'll take one more question
here from the interview uh question
which we have here so uh explain the
concept of a decision Tree in machine
learning
uh explain the concept of decision Tree
in machine learning decision trees are
basically a tree like model that makes
decision by following branches based on
features and it has different criteria
for building the trees you can choose
entropy methods you can choose Guinea
indexes or if it's a regression problem
you can choose mean squar errors to
build the tree and although decision
trees are defined for regression as
classific ification both but as well as
classification both but dees are
predominantly used for classification as
regression it has some limitations and
then you should also explain the
limitation over there and then tell
where you can use it and then you can
also uh also talk about some drawback of
decision trees so you can say that
generally the model overfits and that's
a that's a problem with decision tree
and then also mention but if it overfits
then I can take care of overfitting by
by choosing
different hyper parameter values and
then mention couple of hyper parameter
like Max deps uh minimum sample splits
or or or or the criteria that you're
talking about so that's what you should
answer uh thank you so much amra for
answering that interview question uh so
uh as we have talked about the interview
questions here where we have talked
about the skills here so uh and we have
talked about the career paths you can
take up ANL so before we even move on to
the program part and take up the Q&A
questions we have more interview
questions you know from you folks like
the queries you have shared with us uh
there are plenty of them so we would
love to know what exactly is stopping
you from becoming an AML expert so you
can see a quick p on your screen this is
a multiple choice Port so because there
can be multiple concerns right what's
stopping you from becoming an AML expert
so uh I just read out these options for
you are here so the first one here is I
can find a program with a fully
comprehensive curriculum uh second one I
don't have the Practical exposure I need
to become job ready uh third one I find
it difficult to learn from pre-recorded
videos and the last one my work schedule
won't allow me enough time for learning
so as I was speaking I can see folks
have already started basically sharing
their uh basically responses here on the
poll here just
one but I'll just give 10 seconds more
for the folks who are still choosing uh
in case uh this poll does not CER like
what is your biggest challenge here when
basically want to go for an AIML career
path here and uh or aspire to be an AML
practitioner so what is the biggest
challenge you can let us know on the
chart or in the Q&A box also if this
does not cover your uh basically
challenge here so uh as again like I'm
speaking we have already gotten most of
the responses of the folks here uh so
I'll just give five seconds more uh
before I quickly close this poll so
folks please hurry up and share with us
you know what are the biggest challenges
you face when basically aspiring towards
Amile career
here I'll just give five seconds more so
five four 3 2 1 I'll end the poll uh I
saw that a lot of folks were still
voting I'm so sorry I will have to close
the poll uh so I'll just share the
results with you folks here so let's see
what you folks have shared what is what
are the biggest challenge challenges
here you face uh when basically it comes
to becoming an am an expert here so we
have gotten 65% of the votes here for I
wouldn't get the Practical exposure I
need to become job ready and uh we have
gotten 34% votes here for my worksh
won't allow me enough time for Learning
and we have gotten 29% votes here for I
can't find a program with a fully
comprehensive ccul and few of the wordss
are for I find difficult to learn from
preed videos so thank thank you once
again for sharing that with us now
moving on to the program preview part
here uh so IAT cus professional
certificate course in AI machine
learning here comes with a comprehensive
uh industry aligned learning path uh and
uh you get uh integrated Hands-On labs
and projects for practical experience
which you can work on which we be
talking more about in the upcoming
slides how what are those projects how
you can add those projects to your
portfolio and uh and we have even taken
a project question as well in the
interview so and you get access to on
online virtual classrooms here where you
will uh find a really good peer and
instructor interaction here and also
this program will be flexible to fit
your schedule uh the program tuition for
this one is 11 months and you can just
uh complete it by giving just 10 to 15
hours per week so I just I'm curious
about one thing amra here uh what is the
online virtual classroom environment
looks like you know when it comes to
peers and instructor interaction here is
it like boring or do we find something
you know interesting with every day when
we go for this class can you tell us a
little bit about
that sure so basically
uh the the the platform that we are
talking about is U it's a uh this what
you're saying Russia right the platform
that you're use yeah so this platform is
is fully equipped with with everything
that you need for the training program
so what it does is when you log to your
LMS uh you will be you will be rooted to
your program and there you get certain
self- learning videos that's just for
your health purpose it's not for
something that you have to compulsorily
watch and then only you will understand
the concept that's just for your helping
purpose so you have some self-learning
videos and then you have live virtual
classes now these live virtual classes
will be running from LMS you will get a
link just click on that you'll join the
session an instructor would be there and
they will be teaching you uh the entire
concept
and uh once we are teaching any concept
then it goes like this uh I'm teaching
you suppose decision Tre so I explain
you the mathematics behind that how does
it work what are the uh problems you are
solving with that what kind of
challenges you want you you might come
across and then what I want to do is I
want to implement that concept on a
given problem so then I Define a problem
and I say let's solve it together so
then I need a lab and I need lab in ense
I need the python environment because
that's what we use use generally and and
I also need a data so the LMS provides
everything over there itself so what
will happen you will have a section
where you can download all the data you
can download the problem statements you
can also download the ppts which are
used by instructors and then there is a
link for a lab also so what you dock
click on the lab go to the lab and
whatever instructor is asking you to do
start doing with the instructor onto on
on the lab so what happens this way is
you get a practical understanding of
each problem hands on entirely so you
know how to implement it if you have any
doubt you can simply ask the instructor
there itself that I'm having this
particular problem sometimes in my
classroom what happens that folks are
very new to programming they get stuck
with that I can I simply ask them to
share their screen and show it to me
I'll tell you what's what's going wrong
so that way it's just like a normal
classroom it doesn't feel like it's
doing it you're actually not in a in a
physical classroom because you can show
your lab you can show your notebook you
can ask all the relevant questions and
all in all everything is at at at one
place now not only that if suppose you
you have finished a particular section
then assessment is there only in the LMS
you can click on the assessment uh
finish the assessment and get your
certificate from LMS itself and then if
you get stuck somewhere there's a
helpline available there's a community
support go to the community if you are
solving a problem you need some help
with the trainers go to the community
post to your question one of the trainer
will answer it most of the time my
students can directly write to me also
that also is option so all that is
provided by by our LMS at one place
itself so that's a just just a overview
of the
LMS uh thank you so much for taking us
to the learning environment here for I
cus professional certificate course in
El machine learning uh now at the end of
it all uh you'll be getting a program
completion certificate from IAT kpur
here you can see on your screen
basically how the certificate will look
like and you get exposure to latest
trends like generative AI prompt
engineering charity and more handson
projects which we mentioned earlier
including our Capstone one which will be
talking about in the upcoming slides uh
the master classes delivered by
distinguished IAT Cano faculty you'll
get access to those as well uh now
basically how this program builds your
uh skills here uh step by step I'm so
sorry I think there's a typo here cyber
security but it's IML so uh as we can
see that you start with an induction for
PCP andl machine learning and then we
move on to the mathematics and
statistics Essentials and plus a program
refresher uh then we move upwards to uh
apply data science with python and then
we move on to machine learning and after
machine learning we go through deep
learning with kasas intensive flows and
uh then we cover Essentials of gener
prompt engineering and jity uh and we
basically also work on cap project the
electives here basically are reinforced
learning Advanced deep learning and
computer vision natural language
processing and speech recognition
academic industry master class which we
mentioned earlier so basically the
electives are a part of the program uh
you don't have to pay anything extra for
that so they come as an optional
electives so it is up to you if you want
to take them up uh that is what we
suggest uh and here the you can master
in demand tools libaries and platforms
which you can basically cover in this
program as we can see a lot of these
programs here uh these tools and
libraries platforms here python tensor
flow K stbt mat lip open CV uh open GM
Django uh kubernets flask mid journey
and many more other tools libraries
platforms you can cover in this program
and you get to work on uh projects with
real uh business implications uh as one
of the interview questions which is most
asked is the project right basically
what is the outcome what was the
approach so you actually get access to a
lot of projects you can work on as um
few you can see on the screen here
retail production bfsi and many more
like this uh which basically gives you a
real world experience uh coming from a
completely different background uh as
mentioned earlier we also have Capstone
projects which you can work on which you
can showcase to your future employer
here uh so having a Capone project uh in
your CV basically gives that true
experience you can show in your
portfolio when you're trying to get a
job ready get hired
uh there and the Capt projects which we
have so sorry Capt projects which we
have basically you can choose from so
like I'm pretty sure I'm that they have
this question here that how does exactly
having these projects or a Capt projects
on in their resume uh enhances their
portfolio you know when they are getting
trying to get out there and get an AML
job uh so as we can see that one of the
most asked question is also about the
project right like your approach your
outcome there so can you tell us a
little bit about that no so first of all
Capstone provides you a PR practical
application of knowledge that's the
first thing okay so it gives you a
practical application of knowledge U it
will give you an opportunity to apply
the theoretical knowledge that you have
gained throughout the AIML program to a
real world problem and this hands-on
exper experience is is invaluable in
understanding the Practical challenges
and nuances of implementing AIML ution
because it's a very comprehensive uh
project you need you you you you will be
you will be assist on on everything that
you have learned from day one today to
to to the last last day of your session
so end to endend implementation would be
there so it it will give you a lot of
understanding how a real world problem
is solved that gives you confidence when
you are talking about what did you do in
the last project you can mention it you
can talk about in detail you can mention
that what you have have done how you
have done what was your approach what
challenge you faced what algorithms you
applied how did you fine-tune it all
that you can talk about then as Rasha
mentioned portfolio enhancement
successfully completing a Capstone
project demonstrates your ability to
conceptualize design and execute a
complex AIML project so it will serve as
a valuable addition to your portfolio
and then obviously it is it is for your
skill development so working on a
Capstone project will allow you to hone
your technical skills in data
pre-processing model selection feature
engineering model evaluation and all and
then our our our Capstone is a well
executed Capstone project that will
address a current or relevant industry
challenge so it's very industry relevant
that that's what I can see and then and
then uh problem solving and innovation
in a sense that you can you can up not
only are solving a problem but you can
also try and see what new things you can
apply to it that is also always uh
something which we encourage so that way
it will be very beneficial to you once
you do a Capstone
project uh thank you so much amindra for
answering that in much more detail uh I
hope that basically clears your
questions about the projects you can add
on because you've gotten a lot of
questions regarding the projects part
here uh now uh we have the eligibility I
think few of the folks have asked if
they are eligible for this program or
not so uh basically you need you need to
have a prior knowledge or experience in
programming and Mathematics a bachelor's
degree with an average of 50% or higher
marks and two plus years of former work
experience is preferred when you're
taking up this course here so and we
have global leaders and as program uh
director here uh Professor Kare
basically he's the department of
computer science and engineering uh
basically program director and basically
they make sure that cly learn is
delivering asper standards to IIT can
here uh I think maybe we can take a few
questions here amindra from the Q&A box
here I think as we can see we have
plenty of questions so what I'll do is
I'll just just put down a question for
you in the chat box here for you to
refer uh so because it will be very hard
to find from these many questions we
have here so this is by Raju yadav here
uh Raju here is actually a simply learn
alumni and has recently just joined the
I condo course here so uh as we can see
that Raju has asked basically I'm
working as a teacher in government
primary school and getting salary appro
70,000 uh and also I'm doing my best job
and uh made uh Institute best position
in the state so wow that's that's great
zaju good to hear that and uh but I
always have keen interest in it sector
and doing a job abroad uh I have taken
mission in AIML uh course by I cono from
Simply learn so kindly let me know how
it will be helpful like this course for
me uh in some or the other way uh same
job for my growth uh regards Raju yadav
and also uh he's a graduate from BC
biology uh has not done any course in it
before and uh but he's good with MS
office and other softwares and he has
basically also mentioned his age as 47
so that's that's great like you know
being pretty transparent so first first
of all really proud of you Raju for you
know building a school uh Government
Primary School in your area and making
it the best in your position in your
state so amitra like would you like to
help Raju and answer his query here well
if you're asking uh first of all Raju uh
just want to congratulate on what you
have done it's uh something which I have
been trying to do since ages but I have
not done and it's nice to see somebody
has been doing something like this now
uh when you're asking how program is is
helpful to you already completed I would
say first of all it has it must have
enhanced your problem solving skills the
AIML course generally sharpen your
analytical and problem solving skills
enable you to approach uh challenges
more effectively and in your case it
would be educational challenges if you
are pursuing the same path that you have
chosen and uh it will it will help you
in finding some Innovative solution for
enhancing The Learning Experience of
your students if you want to continue
doing that
uh because I'm not very sure what you're
looking uh uh going forward so if you're
looking to enhance what you have been
doing datadriven teaching approaches
would be a much better approach in terms
of making sure that every student is is
able to optimize their their skill set
so with the knowledge you gain from the
course you can Implement a data driven
teaching methodology which I have been
advocating since long in fact I have
been associated with with couple of
schools over here in Hyderabad where we
we talk about all these con Concepts not
in terms of teaching the students but
telling the management how they can
utilize it and it's pretty good actually
that's more of experience experiment we
have been doing so you can have data
teaching methodology utilizing analytics
and insights to personalize learning for
a students so a lot of things you can do
in the same uh job role that you have
been to and you can integrate technology
to into education talk about AIML and
all curriculum development is something
which you can do based on based on um
certain tools which will be very helpful
which is backed by AIML so something
like that you can do not very sure
what's your career path you're thinking
to choose going uh so he has basically
shared with us on the chart here that
he's interested to innovate rural
students with the help of aim Ah that's
very nice so so as I mentioned earlier
also that like one of like when we have
been talking to some of the schools over
here we talk about like the overall
growth of a student right from the prim
section and when when he or she goes to
the 10th or or 12th board then then over
the period of time we can analyze data
and we can tell what areas they should
focus upon or what they are really good
at their health metrics their their
educational uh performances all that we
analyze and then we tell them that what
what uh kind of focus is required for a
particular student so you can create a
lot of personalized learning
opportunities for the students that's
one thing for sure and then you can also
help them with the with the technology
integration in a sense that Ai and ml
can can facilitate the integration of
technology in the classroom like you you
might be talking about a simple concept
where you can create certain animation
and explain them in a better manner that
kind of stuff you can
do uh thank you so much am for answering
raju's question Raju please let us know
in chat here if that basically answers
your question and also keep up the good
work which you're trying to do so uh
thank you so much for that and uh moving
on we'll take a lot of these questions
here we have gotten in the Q&A box uh so
uh we have talked about the skills we
have talked about the career paths uh we
have talked about the projects you can
work on a caption project you can
basically add to your uh portfolio once
you have done with the project so uh we
have a quick poll question here would
you like to enroll into the professional
certificate course inl by Cano so uh
just also just to mention we have a
bonus offer for you for attending this
webinar so uh like please don't miss on
the bonus offer for attend this webinar
for this program which if you like would
like to enroll and also you can
basically there's a timeline of
enrollment as well I'll be asking about
that as well when do you plan to enroll
so even if you're planning to enroll
even more than six months from now you
can still Avail on the bonus offer for
attending the webinar you'll be getting
for this program uh um as I was speaking
I can see a lot of interest coming
towards enrollment so that's great we
have gotten a lot of folks here
basically who aspire to be an expert
here and I'm definitely sure we'll do
great things uh you know uh as we can
see you know like Raju actually is one
of the alumni who recently joined the
course plans to basically innovate rural
stents and with the help of a im so
that's great and also I think someone is
asking about the webinar content in PDF
so the thing is we cannot share the
content PDF but definitely it'll be
sharing the recording link of the
session post webinar over mail so you
can look out for that and you will get
that recording L can go through it in
much more detail so Prince I hope that
answers your question
I'll just keep the SPO live for 15
seconds more meanwhile as we browse
through the Q&A questions here so we'll
be taking your queries from the Q&A box
here pretty soon folks so in case you
have any questions about the program orl
career in general the interview prep
questions in general you can let us know
uh we uh basically uh have surpassed the
timing of the webinar but we'll just
give like few more minutes
uh just for the addressing all of your
queries here amra will you be okay with
that like it'll take like five minutes
more for addressing their queries yeah
that's perfectly fine NAA not a problem
okay awesome awesome so uh once again
there's a quick put on your screen uh
would you like to enroll into the
professional certificate course by AIA
uh in case you want to check out the
course uh in mcho detail uh you can I'm
sharing the link here on chat here you
can go through that link here also uh
I'll be sharing the program schedule and
the program fee in the upcoming slides
and the enrollment steps for to
basically give you a much better
understanding how the enrollment Works
once basically have shared your interest
so uh so yeah I think folks have already
started like putting down more questions
in the Q that's great uh you can see a
quick PLL in the screen here basically
for the enrollment part of the program
here so please do let us know our
interest towards enrollment by just
clicking on yes on the poll here and uh
this way you can Avail on the bonus
offer as well you'll be getting uh to
attend this webinar today uh for the uh
basically professional certificate
course
in okay I think uh I can see most of the
folks have already shared uh in their
responses on the poll here so I'll just
quickly end this poll in 5 seconds so 5
4 3 2
yes I've ended the poll here and once
again thank you so much for sharing your
interest with us for enrollment part so
folks who already shared the interest
here towards enrollment let me quickly
take you through the enrollment steps
here so the enrollment uh steps
basically are three simple steps here
you need to submit an application to us
at ask us at simple.net uh based on that
your application will be going for a
review and based on the eligibility and
prees you have shared with you based on
that you'll be getting uh ad missions
offer letter and simply learns learning
Consultants will be reaching out to you
uh to take you through the program uh in
much more detail uh so and also as I
said that if you basically need any
assistance you can always reach out to
us at ask simply on I've shared that
email ID on the chart here the
enrollment schedule and the program fee
for this uh program by IAT kpur is uh 1
lakh 15,400 including taxes Ina and in
case you're joining from a different
region I have shared the link to the
program here on chat you can basically
go and check it out for your own region
as well uh and uh I think someone asked
about if there are any EMA options
available for this program so yes we do
have and you can just Avail that at
5,222 rupees per month and the upcoming
cohorts for this uh particular program
is uh on 18th of November and the
induction will be starting on first week
of November so in case basically you're
planning to enroll we only take 25 to 30
folks per coh in order to make sure
you're getting all the attention that is
required when you're taking up the
program and uh if you have any questions
you can always reach out to us at ask us
at s.net I have shared that email ID on
the chat box here and also uh as we saw
that a lot of you folks have shared
interest towards the enrollment into the
program so uh we would also love to know
when do you basically plan to enroll how
soon do you plan to enroll into the
program so there are four quick options
here uh immediately within 3 months
within 6 months more than six months
from now so so uh I would recommend for
folks who are looking for um the next
upcoming C in the next few months next
two months or so you can select the
option immediately because I've shared
there is an upcoming CT we can join in
November and in case you need more time
I can select the within three months
option or within six months option and
folks who are still thinking about it
planning about it but have shared their
interest towards enrollment I would say
don't miss out on the bonus offer right
so you have already shared that with us
so uh you can select them more than six
months from op you can still Avail the
bonus offer through that so uh as I was
speaking I can see folks have already
started sharing when do the plan to
enroll uh we'll be quickly moving
towards the Q&A part of the session
after this and uh addressing uh you know
a few of your queries as much as we can
uh because we have already exted the
time of the session by five minutes here
uh so I'll just quickly end the poll in
5 seconds so few of the folks who are
still sharing when do they plan to
enroll uh I'll just give five seconds
for that so 5 4 3 2 1
thank you so much for sharing that with
us uh now going to the Q&A part here so
let's just uh I'm going to quickly
browse through the questions here
obviously there are so many questions so
let me do one thing uh I think you have
answered few questions as well right as
you were uh answering the interview uh
prep Master Class questions so maybe
uh okay I think this is an interesting
one I'll just put this down on the chart
for you because it will be very hard to
find it in so many questions we have so
uh the name is not mentioned here but
for any interview the question is always
uh give the give me practical issues
which you faced on a IML and how did you
overcome those challenges how can we
answer it and if we don't have much
practical hands-on
experience okay you do not have much
practical handson if you lack practical
hands-on experience in AML you can
approach the interview question by by
emphasizing your theoretical knowledge
problem solving skills and your ability
to adopt and learn quickly probably
something like this you can do like you
can you can talk about uh uh emphasize
on your your strong grasp of AIML
Concepts algorithms
methodologies uh gain through whatever
course we talking about you have
completed and relevant projects
capstones that you have worked upon and
then try to demonstrate a problem
solving skills you can talk about
discuss instances where you have tackled
a complex problem uh during your program
during your Capstone or whatever project
you have done uh and if they were not
directly related to AIML suppose and and
you do not have many to Showcase then
showcase your ability to analyze
challenges critically break them down
into manageable component
and devise effective Solution that's
what we are doing in machine learning
right we are taking a problem breaking
down into multiple component so as long
as we see generally I I'll tell you like
if I have to As Long As I see that a
person has a good problem solving skill
and they have some technical background
I can say technical background in the
sense they have learned few few things
and it seems that the uh as the person
is Keen to learn and adopt I would be
happy to have him in my team so
demonstrate your problem solving skills
uh talk about your adaptability and
learning uh agility I would say that how
do you how you have learned new
technology or how how you have uh uh
quickly grasped A New Concept that
that's what you can talk about or some
projects personal projects that you can
you might have done probably you might
have uh participated in hackathon or
probably you have downloaded from kagle
you saw it and explain to them that what
steps you have taken and how did you
solve so I guess if you do that much it
will convey this this this uh
understanding that you have keen know
you have keen uh uh I would say you have
a knack of problem solving and you are
very keen in terms of adapting to new
technology and uh you're passionate
about IM IML and that would surely get
you a particular job role that you're
looking
for uh thank you so much am for
answering that we don't have an em here
so please do let us know in chat here in
case you have any followup questions or
if that answers your question uh we have
actually an interesting uh you know like
a question here uh is actually your
student yeah CH I think CH is what I can
make from the email ID so I'm just put
down that question for you on the chat
here so I have enrolled into the program
by simply learn recently and I'm
attending amit's lecture uh my main
question is how to start career in AIM
and currently working embedded
Engineering in automotive
industry okay I can I can uh Recall now
CH is part of my math and statistics
essential that I'm taking for Caltech
these days hey J nice to catch up with
you here
so so you are saying that uh how to
start a career in AIML currently working
in Engineering in automative industry so
if you're asking the entire like how you
go about it I would say that uh finish
your mean go through your foundation uh
in programming language pick up python I
would say for sure if you pick up python
R will become very easy or Ys say Versa
any one programming language you pick up
other would become very easy so pick up
python for sure and then uh uh
understand how the data structures and
algorithms work in Python and then
uh you
start uh dive deep into the course work
that we are providing uh understand like
any algorithm that you are learning uh
learn what the con what is the concept
behind it where you use it and a couple
of things even if somebody's not telling
you find it on on your own like what
kind of challenges you face in that
particular algorithm what limitations
would be there and how to handle those
problems so I would say do that for
every algor algorithm because it's not
possible to explain you algorithm for
four five hours that we we explain to
you what's the basic concept and how
does it work and apart from that some
some basic basic problems that you might
come across but I would say go entirely
in detail that what kind of challenges
or what kind of limitations are there
for each one of them and then Hands-On
practice is very important so for every
algorithm that you are learning any
concept that you are learning uh relate
to a particular business problem and
then see how you can solve that so
undertak some practical a IML projects
that you might come across in on on
you'll find so many on internet and
experiment with the data set apply
different algorithms focus on
understanding the nuances of
implementing AIML Solution that's what I
keep saying that concept is important
but even more important is uh in terms
of how do you tweak a particular
algorithm how do you customize it or how
do you fine-tune it that's that's even
more important and then eventually I
would say one more thing is is that
don't forget get to network and
collaborate with different people be
very active on on on LinkedIn and all I
would say that to everyone of you that
that if you want to make your career in
this particular field start interacting
with people who are already working in
this particular field okay and that way
when the opportunity comes to for a
particular company you will have
somebody working over there and
references work very well when you are
looking for a job okay so that's what I
would say and and and to end and on this
that uh you have to
you have to uh stay updated because
every now and then something new comes
up so you have to continuously learning
new topics New Concepts which are coming
so that's what I would that's what the
that's what you should do uh going
forward
sh uh thank you so much for answering
that uh I think uh we have actually the
time of the session so uh we'll be uh
like stopping um taking questions from
the Q&A box here so so folks who have
already shared uh they want to enroll
and basically when do you plan to enroll
uh please do let us know on the quick
poll which you see on your screen here
is do you need assistance in enrolling
to the ID compost professional
certificate course in uh artificial
intelligence and machine learning uh so
uh and also uh thank you so much amendra
for you know like taking the time out
and basically taking us through the
interview prep master class and also
sharing your experience as well you know
in your own interview days
uh to be honest like we have so many
questions uh you know always in your
program but obviously this time of
duration we cannot cover all of them uh
but uh we basically keep coming up with
these new webinars and uh you know with
in the coming months uh we will uh be
having again another webinar with
amindra for sure uh so you can basically
check out those webinars in this link
that sharing you can check out free
master classes which you can attend
which basically will give you a better
understanding of all the basically
courses or uh you know maybe like the
dream job you are looking for to explore
that much more through these webinars uh
which will might give you a little bit
Clarity on you know which uh basically
stream to pursue so uh thank you so much
once again am would you like to say
something uh before we close the
session uh first of all uh thank you so
much Rasha for having me here it's
always pleasure talking to you on
different concepts and um to all of you
I would just like to say this that uh uh
just uh focus on Basics and uh I know
you will do well uh so best of luck to
all of
you uh thank you once again amendra and
I would love to thank folks here for
being an amazing audience here and also
you know uh basically taking up so many
interesting questions here which we got
in the Q&A box uh thank you so much for
engaging and with us and again like
thank you so much for taking the time
out and joining this free interview
master class today so once again please
do let us know how was the session
session for you uh today uh I hope that
gave you a little bit understanding
about the interview prep master class uh
and before we even end the session I
just have a quick uh po survey question
PO for you so uh this poll basically is
to understand what topics or areas of
Interest would you like to see covered
in the future webinars here so uh this
interview prep again was one of the uh
you know one of the new categories of
webinars which we have done with amindra
here forl but would love to know like on
the quick poll you see here I'll just
read these options for you uh so uh as
you can seear the first option here is
project uh program project demos uh
second one uh resume enh enhancement
resum review and tips uh and uh the
third one interview pration which we
have just done now and uh fourth one
case studies fifth one uh soft skills
development um and then Trends uh
industry specific insights project
reviews uh so project demos and project
previews are totally different basically
project demos are basically what project
demos are covered in this program uh in
particular programs of the courses the
webinar is for project previews is for
for someone who's actually completed the
project and also uh wants a basically
quick review uh you know through our
expert here so uh that is one of the
options and career advancement
strategies as I was speaking we have
already started getting a lot of
responses the PO here but I'll just give
10 seconds more because we would love to
know what exactly do you look forward to
uh when you basically attend our
webinars here and we would want to make
it better for you and as much value
adding as possible uh you can get out of
this uh I think someone has asked on the
chat here that when will the recording
be so you can access Anand if you are
you current simply LM because you have
written LMS uh but uh you basically be
getting if just just in attende you'll
be getting the recording of This webinar
over mail post webinar and also folks
basically who want the certificate of
the web this webinar you can basically
go and check out the post webinar survey
email you'll be getting in that please
do mention your full name which
basically you would want to see in the
webinar certificate uh folks basically
who are not putting down their full name
in the post webinar survey we won't be
giving out webinar certificates for them
so apologies in advance for that okay
awesome uh I think we' have gotten the
responses here on the survey so thank
you so much for sharing that with us
we'll be taking a note of all the
suggestions you have given on the poll
here and we'll be imp implementing those
categories of webinars and coming with
many new webinars with you along with am
so uh so thank you again once everyone
for joining thank you once again am for
joining and taking us through this
interesting interview prep master class
uh we'll be ending the session now again
like thank you once again everyone uh
thank
you